[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
waouh on commence la vidéo comme ça
bonjour comment ça va ou est-ce qu'on
est aujourd'hui on est au hellfest vous
avez une grande fille derrière parce que
vous avez sepultura qui est en train de
signer des autographes sur des pochettes
ils font des bisous ils font des câlins
et aujourd'hui on n'est pas là pour près
de cette culture a bien qu'on soit là
pour parler de musique on parle de
marshall un barebone doc c'est une
petite enceinte que vous allez emmener
partout avec vous et les plantureuses on
a du son stéréo qu'on va en parler et on
va en parler dans le lieu cultissime du
rock du métal en france ici à clisson et
il fait juste 38 degrés on crève roman
peu plus on a beau avoir les casquettes
lunettes de soleil et puis petit
chantier un peu moins vite qu'on crève
quand même mais on s'en fout parce qu'on
est là pour du bon sauf et que comme du
bon sang qu'est-ce qu'on fait marshall
conso sont les jambes rock'n'roll les
amplis marshall de son art schalke
connaissait y soit on adore et en plus
c'est vachement solide allez c'est parti
honni la dnat au
sat à peine 700 grammes ce titre qu'on
peut l'emmener partout en mélangeant sac
à dos avec soin on est dans l'air pour
vous m enfin pas ici parce que déjà la
très bonne musique on n'a pas besoin de
ce petit système l'aménorrhée dans un
petit camion comme y opposer à tout cas
mieux net c'est plutôt cool ils sont
deux coloris contient blagues grasses
comme ça et vous avez également la
couleur kim et en plus c'est vachement
bien c'est que vous pouvez vraiment tous
les codes de marshall c'est à dire le
petit côté cuivre et en os sur la marque
vous avez tout le tour en silicone ici
qui est fait à partir de plastique
recyclé 50 % de plastique recyclé et ici
c'est sans pvc donc c'est très très cool
retrouve la grille en métal à l'avant
mais également de l'autre côté alors
pour savoir où l avant c'est là où il ya
écrit marshall de la copc pas aigri
surtout vachement vire très facile à
prendre en main et puis une fois de plus
le petit bouton avancé un petit bouton
directionnelle qui est génial en fait ce
petit mouton c'est le bouton unique
c'est juste un petit bouton bluetooth
nous on s'en fou celui là vous appuyez
longtemps fait on vous appuyez longtemps
vous faites offre une fois lecture une
fois pause vous
vous changez les morceaux joués par 35
des trucs ça suffira c'est très simple
sénart ça va c'est bien comme ça bravo
marche aller acheter un petit truc
important ici vous venez de recharger
juste ici on y laisse des ces pratiques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ont lieu les 11 et le vide ans et vous
le pourrez le regarder ma casquette et
la fée meilleures cascades à je te jure
qu'il y aurait autant pour la casquette
motivé la tequila cause est plutôt ça ça
fonctionne avec du bluetooth cinq points
c'est pratique ça vous donne quoi ça
vous donne 10 m de porteils pour je peux
me reculer un peu et on est peinard
regardez je vous le disais il ya deux
boutons dessus technique une fois et
aurait mis alors là jamais un peu sans
la connaître
l'éolien après ce poste on est là pour
écouter de la musique à fond
bien des faits
mais je bosse jeunesse comme sa mort en
janvier juste un truc là
m aux ailes tu peux jouer pendant dix
ans absolument ridicule que c'est très
cool c'est vachement notamment bâti
maria mesalles importante de ces
l'intérieur j'ai quoi j'ai tout rose
auteur à large bande au pouce et j'ai dû
moi de byzance
génialement de radiateur fassi
[Musique]
si on entend à
360° trou stereophonics ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'en fait vous avez
déjà stéréo et l'inspiré ou pas c'est
quoi si vous avez un plat un haut
parleur gauche euros par le roi et le
son a mis de côté vous êtes au milieu et
le son j'arrive à droite et à gauche à
une amélioration du nageur sauf qu'ici
c'est pas car c'est une petite enceinte
blindée pedro rouge de ré aucune notion
de stereophonics n'existe participe à
brossard à faire aux médias ces normes
sont effectivement deux canaux vous
savez tous ont pu ford façade avant qui
sont passés par ailleurs il ya ni
réellement façade avant ni et moi j'en
arrière 6 mai si le marché le permet de
différencier mais on réalise été malin
pourquoi je pense que geoffrey avec des
amis il fait de la toge rouge posé sur
une table sur des pages tant qu'il tient
uniquement de l'art vous avez le temps
qu'il vient de partout tout autour si
cette leçon il va sortir comme ça je
sais pas combien de degrés d'ouverture
on avait trouvé son sort dommage pour du
sort de là et en fait vous avez vous pu
musulmans tout autour parce que le son
on trouvera quand même même sur les
côtés donc ça c'est vache beaucoup c'est
très chouette en expériences avec des
années passées le premier pas est ce
jeune pro intéressant c'est le
stagnation de sa crotte sait quoi faire
penser que vous avez provenir les joints
entre elton brand 12h01 permet de
déconnecter une salle aux murs de
marshall c'est qu'on se doit
encore fini mais l'expérience de tags
partout peut-être même du multi rôle
direct si vous avez des bois on va quand
même mur dans les conseils pour
notamment au fbi et ça c'est vachement
bien faut alors vous en mettez un droit
de la gauche et quelles que soient les
ombres en relief c'est d'avoir le même
son même si les entraîneurs passent
partout chez vous et ça c'est pas je
m'en viens
qu'est ce que ça raconte au niveau
expérience audio
laure chailloux dit on à eau sont bien
vivants je suis d'accord le son et vos
leçons de bonne qualité alors attention
on est quand même sur les petit haut
parleur même s'ils développent quand
même de la puissance à 306 plutôt cool
mais est ce qu'il faut savoir ici c'est
que le son il va pas être aussi bons que
sur les très grosses enceintes marshall
ça me paraissait normal peu plus c'est
une expérience qu'on avait à part c'est
vraiment l'idée de prendre son enceinte
et cela met dans la poche voyez je la
prends je la mets dans mon slip et je
veux voir avec tout ça c'est vachement
pratique mais surtout ce qu'offre
l'espace avait quand même très bonne
année on a toujours après cette
signature marshall qu'on a trouvé ce
sont là et rock'n'roll c'est à dire que
l'on va pas avoir de grosses bases comme
ce week-end des radiateurs passifs on
attend rhône est un axe mais malgré tout
le son est clair le son est de bonne
qualité pour avoir une bonne expérience
audio foi des croyants sonore ses vaches
beaucoup
[Musique]
là il fut 30 heures d'autonomie alors
vous nouveau changer en quoi en trois
heures ok ok ok attention séquence
parfois on a besoin de rechange en cas
de nul on est tranquille là dessus pour
changer en trois heures pour vous
anticipez un peu d'aller faire là bas
l'année si vous n'avez pas anticipé en
20 minutes de charge pour paris pour
quatre heures musique qui non content
vraiment hard rock avec des notes vous y
allez vous leur changer rapidement donc
ça reste malgré tout extrêmement rapide
déjà c'est bien et en plus la regarder
sur le côté vous avez un petit voyant de
batteries lorsque je vais venir pour
monter baisser le son ça me permet de
savoir exactement où j'en suis au niveau
de ma batterie et c'est cool parce que
lorsque vous êtes avec des amis oui que
ça commence à flancher vous pouvez
anticiper ça c'est cool
[Musique]
et on a ici une application qui vous
servira à venir régler un peu tout ce
que voulait notamment mettre un
équaliseur alors vous direz vous c'est
plus importante mais régler les
équaliseurs lorsque vous le faites avec
des petits bugs mais vous pouvez faire
également ici alors vous voyez beaucoup
plus que moi parce qu'il ya tellement de
lumière joba grand chose j'ai quand même
mes réglages des polisseurs voyez
l'association chal gpush gvoice safia
modifier le son marchand propose c'est
ce qui va le mieux quand même et ça
marche alors ce qui conviendra le mieux
est ici je vous dis ça vient changer un
petit peu mais ça change pas non plus
complètement l'histoire ça c'est assez
sympa on est de l'application des votes
mode ce pack on y règle pour mettre tout
pesant 50 burton ii ensemble c'est très
cool que apple la mise à jour du
firmware directement vous faites une
bière en fait avec la joie sur ces
directement ça sonnait combat lancé pour
mettre à jour le firmware et vous mettez
votre musique live pose directement
partir de smartphones elles sont aussi
très facilement et ça aussi c'est
chouette et en plus de ça elle et ip 67
ça veut dire quoi résistante à l'eau et
à la poussière
[Musique]
ça donne quoi cette marche our town 269
euros c'est le prix déjà il faut le
savoir revoir votre enceinte dans la
couleur de votre choix moi j'aime bien
je trouve pourquoi ils écoulent déjà
parce que ces marchés que j'aime
beaucoup la marque marshall j'en ai déjà
parlé plusieurs fois j'ai un rapport
affectif affectueux une histoire vraie
avec marshall au premier rang picard
break plein de souvenirs du passé mais
également du présent et surtout du
présent avec cette petite enclave elle
est bien les pratiques vous la mettez
pas tous égaux il est d'abord le son
stéréo un peu tous les côtés ça c'est
vachement bien aussi pour que tout le
monde profite dans son qualité à droite
et à gauche bref vous avez ce qu'il faut
vous avez un robot qui marche bien
j'aime bien le trouve intéressante donc
si elle vous intéresse bien évidemment
j'aime et pourra jouer le lien juste en
bas dans la description et le plaisir
malin bertone d'eau disponible dans une
couleur et ça c'est cool un voile à
visionner petit lapin nous on voulait ce
parce que déjà on va se désaltérer qui
fait une chaleur apocalyptique est
d'accord l'ailé là j'ai un petit 39
degrés soleil ça va continuer à monter
donc là heureusement qu'ils nous arrose
on est bien on est heureux on est au
pays ou paradis du métal ici à clisson
très heureux d'être un où elle fait son
premier week-end sera également là sur
le deuxième week end c'est très chouette
merci à vous d'avoir été présent leur a
fait vivre une petite espèce très très
court et puis si ça intéresse il ya la
vidéo récap du hellfest qui arrivera
d'ici quelques temps peut-être une vidéo
peut-être de vidéos je sais pas
exactement ce qui va se passer donc on
va continuer à s'immerger dans le monde
merveilleux du métal des faits cela on
était branché à musique avec marchal
morel faire avec une espérance beaucoup
plus rock'n'roll attention on prendra
plein d'autres choses donc stable qui
peut d'ailleurs ma gêne ça va être très
chaud et 12 ans bras un bisou à bientôt
pour les soins de peau et nova voir
parce que ce soit pour la triste
tellement ça
[Musique]
à